[Music]
I'm Anthony mangieri of Hoonah Pete
Sinopoli Tanana Lower East Side New York
City well the concept of this restaurant
is really inspired by the pizza of
Naples but kind of like my own twist on
that for me Neapolitan pizza is what I
make because my family is from there and
what I would say is that it's cooked in
a wood-fired oven it's round it's about
12 inches it's served whole it's not
sliced so I don't know if we're making
here is exactly classified like it's
Neapolitan pizza well if you're making
it the way that we do here the dough is
not refrigerated and it's naturally
leavened so you're dealing with like an
element that's slightly under control
and slightly out of control and then you
add in the factor of the oven which
there's no real accurate temperature
controls so I think Neapolitan pizza at
its best and when it's really magical is
when it's riding that line between
perfection and disaster
so the way that we make the pizza here
is the dough is natural 11 so there's no
commercial use in it and it's never
refrigerated it takes two days for it to
raise from beginning to end it's a very
wet though it's super highly hydrated
and what that allows me to do is create
a dough that's very puffy around the
crust and kind of wild I take the dough
out of the tray and I flatten it very
gently very quickly try to leave as much
air in it as possible so that has
character and life then I put the tomato
sauce on it which is the same as oh no
tomatoes from around Naples then I put
the buffalo mozzarella on it which we
cut in cubes one of the big things with
the mozzarella for me is the way that it
melts American mozzarella when it melts
usually dries flatter on the pizza gets
little holes in it it'll get like little
brown spots it's beautiful but it just
not for what I'm looking for then I use
for Sicilian sea salt and drop any fresh
basil which is locally grown if possible
the Sorrento olive oil I want everything
on the pizza to be balanced and even I
don't want one ingredient to be over
another they're kind of working together
as one and then we slide it on to the
pizza peel and then it goes into the
oven once it's in the oven I use little
pieces of wood shavings which is a very
old technique from Naples what the wood
shavings do is they give a little burst
of temperature and it's a temperature
that's just air heat it's not actually
changing the stone temperature the oven
is from Naples it's called the McCune
toe and the design on them are exactly
the same as the design on the ovens in
Pompeii and it just creates this perfect
circulation of heat and it cooks for
like a minute to a minute and a half
take it out and that's
[Music]
my family is from Naples and I fell in
love with Naples when I was a young kid
and will go there and eat that pizza it
just tasted so ethnic it's like so not
American and kind of became evident that
this is really where my heart is and
where I belong so I started and I opened
the first tuna pizza in 1996 for me at
this point of my life like I don't think
that the pizzas the best I think that
it's just mine and it's what I offer so
people come in I hope that they
appreciate that the pizza that you get
here is kind of unique to this place
and to me into everyone here as we work
as a team so that's what I bring to New
York I've been myself and my ideas and
my independence in the way that I do
things
[Music]